[Musique]
l'usine de batterie pour véhiculer
électrique de Volkswagen est un
investissement qui va bénéficier à
plusieurs générations à lui seul ce
projet va permettre de créer jusqu'à
3000 emplois directs et jusqu'à 30 000
emplois indirects
l'investissement est énorme 13 milliards
de dollars sur 10 ans en subvention et
700 millions de dollars pour financer
les coûts de construction
Ottawa n'a rien ménagé pour convaincre
Volkswagen devenir construire à
Saint-Amé son Ontario sa première usine
à l'extérieur du continent européen le
gouvernement veut ainsi faire
concurrence au généreuses incitatif de
l'inflation de Joe Biden mais
l'investissement fait tout de même sur
scier est-ce nécessaire d'aller aussi
loin j'en discute avec le ministre de
l'innovation des Sciences et de
l'Industrie François Philippe champagne
bonjour merci d'être avec nous merci
Monsieur Thibault de m'avoir à votre
émission aujourd'hui le champagne il y a
des gens qui disent que 13 milliards de
dollars plus de 700 millions vont la
construction de l'usine c'est cher payé
pour l'investissement vous dites quoi
bah je dis un retour sur
l'investissement 5 ans c'est plutôt un
bon investissement de Stacy ce qui
compte c'est que ce qu'on dit c'est que
le retour sur l'investissement il est de
5 ans dans un investissement qui est
générationnel le monsieur chose que vous
allez voir ici à saint-anto Metz ça sera
le plus grand site manufacturier au
Canada on parle d'équivalent je pensais
378 terrain de football le président de
la campagne de Monsieur champagne du
stationnement jusqu'à l'usine c'est 1.6
km alors je pense que ce qui est
important pour les gens de comprendre on
gagne jamais avec l'argent on est le
Canada la raison pour qu'on a gagné
aujourd'hui c'est grâce au travailleur
c'est grâce aux écosystèmes qu'on a bâti
les minéraux critiques l'énergie
renouvelable l'accès au marché c'est ce
qui fait qu'on a gagné aujourd'hui dans
une compétition qui est l'argent dire
quand vous regardez mais l'argent compte
un peu aussi quand même c'est quand la
vie c'est quand la dernière fois que
vous avez déposé un chèque de 13
milliards de dollars pour attirer un
investissement au Canada mais là pour
être là on parle pas de ça aujourd'hui
tout d'abord avant même qu'il y a du
support pour la production monsieur
Thibault juste qu'on soit clair avec les
auditeurs les auditrices Volkswagen doit
elle-même investir 7 milliards pour
construire l'usine et seulement
lorsqu'ils auront commencé à produire et
vendre des batteries
selon les règles aussi de la rue aux
États-Unis et sur 10 ans il y aura un
support à ce moment-là donc c'est ça qui
est important de comprendre d'abord il
faut Volkswagen doit investir 7
milliards pour ça que je vous dis et si
vous regardez une usine comme c'est là
vous parlez de pour faire fonctionner
l'usine en terme de salaire en terme de
dépenses vous reparler d'un demi vous
parlez d'un milliard par année pour
opérer une usine comme cela alors ce qui
compte je pense pour les gens c'est vrai
que c'est un montant important mais
l'importance aussi de l'investissement
parce que quand je parlais au PDG de la
campagne de Monsieur champagne on n'est
pas là pour 10 ans voilà pour 20 ans on
n'est pas pour te randonné 1%. alors
vous comprendrez que nous quand on a
calculé si vous regardez sur une échelle
de 30 ans vous parlez d'un bénéfice
économique pour le Canada environ de 200
à 400 milliards monsieur Thibault et si
vous prenez un budget fédéral prépare
des mix vous parlez de 300 milliards
donc c'est énorme ce que ça ça va amener
au Canada parce que ils vont amener
l'ensemble de leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement chez nous au pays
est-ce que c'est comme ça est-ce que
c'est un coup d'investissement ces gens
là qu'on est capable de combattre les
actions
à la table mais ce qui nous permet de
gagner monsieur Thibault je vais le
répéter sur toutes les tribunes c'est
grâce au travers et travailleurs parce
que c'est vraiment la qualité de notre
main-d'oeuvre qui fait qu'on est capable
de gagner parce que vous comprendrez que
une compagnie comme Volkswagen aurait pu
obtenir ce même niveau de support là
financier n'importe où au monde ils
l'ont fait en Espagne ils l'ont fait en
Allemagne et je peux vous dire la
compétition était féroce avec nos amis
du Sud mais ce qui a permis de gagner
c'est l'énergie renouvelable c'est
l'action matière critique c'est la force
la qualité de la main d'oeuvre qu'on a
développé chez nous et c'est ce qui voit
dans le Canada ce qui fait la différence
c'est ce que c'est la vision qu'on s'est
donné d'être un leader dans
l'électrification des transports est-ce
que c'est est-ce que c'est la norme
maintenant c'est ça parce que là il y a
d'autres compagnies là qui vous
regardent qui sont peut-être intéressés
à venir investir au Canada aux
États-Unis qui se disent ah ben il faut
demander de l'argent parce qu'il y a de
l'argent à aller chercher sa table à
Ottawa
mais je pense que le monde a changé je
pense que on est en train de vivre une
transformation industrielle et numérique
comme on n'a jamais vu c'est pour ça que
moi je parle souvent de d'opportunité
générationnelle vous savez on passe d'un
moteur à essence un moteur électrique
qu'on voit que les grandes chaînes
d'approvisionnement qui était mondiale
se régionalise qu'on met plus d'enfants
sur la résilience et ça c'est un monde
je vous dirais monsieur Thibault le
Canada peut gagner c'est un monde qui
offre des possibilités aux travailleurs
canadien où on peut mettre de l'avant
les les forces du Canada mais vous êtes
prêtes vous êtes prêtes à investir
là-dedans en notant qu'il y a un retour
sur l'investissement moi je vois ça plus
comme un investissement si le retour sur
l'investissement est là je pense que
tout le monde comprend si on veut
générer des revenus on doit investir
c'est vrai dans une famille c'est vrai
dans une compagnie c'est vrai dans un
gouvernement mais c'est sûr que on est
le Canada il faudrait être très
stratégique ça sera limité ça sera
vraiment ciblé mais c'est ce qu'on a
fait aujourd'hui
qui sont les prochains parce que je sais
que vous êtes en discussion on de rester
lentilles si on parle de LG est-ce que
est-ce qu'on est rendu où est-ce qu'on
en est rendu dans ces conversations là
on a des discussions on a des
négociations c'est clair mais comme je
vous disais le premier c'est évoqué
aussi plutôt ça sera limité ça sera avec
seulement quelques compagnies vous savez
on n'est pas les États-Unis on peut pas
on peut pas se permettre d'avoir un
éventail aussi large mais ce qui est
important pour moi comme les industrie
du Canada c'est de garder cette
proportion là qu'il y a une proportion
entre l'industrie canadienne américaine
pour assurer la pérennité de l'industrie
automobile chez nous parce que vous
comprenez ici on fait pas ces
investissements là un jour le Canada ne
serait plus j'allais dire dans la mire
des grands constructeurs automobiles
parce qu'on n'aurait pas fait cette
transition là c'est un investissement
aussi dans dans la transition éternelle
qui est en lien je pense avec les
valeurs des gens de chez nous on
recevait pierre à l'émission la semaine
dernière il y a une déception du côté de
Québec parce qu'on aurait bien voulu
pouvoir attirer ce genre là au Québec
aussi
il y a différentes raisons qui ont fait
en sorte que ça s'en va Ontario mais
est-ce que c'est exclu dans les
prochains projets comment vous voyez ce
que est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose pour
le Québec dans l'avenir bah oui moi je
travaille pour tout le monde puis je
voudrais un monsieur Thibault le Québec
est rentré par la grande porte dans
l'industrie automobile avec JM pascu à
bécancourt suivant la blague quand les
gens te courent parlent de bécancourt je
me dis on en a fait grand-chose
l'industrie automobile est beaucoup en
Ontario pas tellement au Québec écoutez
ben justement on est en train de la
bâtir avec Monsieur fadigaben parce que
c'était pas une industrie on était
vraiment présent mais là avec JM c'est
la grande porte là nous on rentre pas
par la porte d'Hanna hier et c'est sûr
qu'on est en train de regarder d'autres
projets mais je peux vous dire le projet
de gemme à bécancourt l'usine de
becancourt Monsieur Thibault sera la
plus stratégique de toutes les usines de
Gien parce que toutes les unes de James
en Amérique du Nord vont
s'approvisionner à partir de bécancourt
quand vous parlez au PDG de JM aux
États-Unis vous dit beckenco c'est
l'usine la plus importante de toutes ces
usines en Amérique du Nord mais surtout
on s'est placé où il y a de la valeur
ajoutée parce qu'on sait que ce qu'on
fait avec en cours ça représente 65 % de
la valeur ajoutée et ça représente
ensuite la batterie correspond à 40% de
la valeur du véhicule alors moi j'ai
c'est fini le temps où à l'époque on
prenait nos ressources pour les envoyer
là cette fois là on s'insère dans dans
la partie où il y a le plus de valeur
ajoutée puis ça se fait chez nous à
becquencourt au Québec François Philippe
champagne merci infiniment d'avoir été
des nôtres toujours un plaisir merci à
vous bonne journée